[Music]
let's use multiple cursors with posits
our studio IDE these can be super useful
when you have to do finicky text
manipulation tasks within a document or
in your code let's see how all this
works running through your options with
an example suppose we have this artist
table and we want to convert into a
vector of just the artists first let's
create a few extra cursors we're going
to use option control and then use the
up or down arrow on a Mac or control and
ALT in the up or down arrow on Windows
now let's move around and select some
text using the shift and arrow keys
we're going to use command and the arrow
key to jump to the end of the line then
use shift in the option key plus some
arrows to select the comma and years
note that we're selecting across
multiple lines and then backspace to
delete that and then on the keyboard
just forward delete to move all of these
into one line and now just a little bit
of R code to convert these into a vector
called artists so far in this example we
use just keyboard shortcuts to create
multiple cursors across multiple lines
but you could also used your mouse on
Windows use alt and then click and drag
to select multiple lines and then on a
Mac hold